the heart of government sri lanka's
presidential secretariat was surrounded
by thousands of protesters who then
stormed the building
from the morning clashes between
protesters and security forces have
taken place across the capital city
colombo
undeterred by tear gas police firing in
the air and water cannons protesters
gathered to march on the president's
house to force him out of office
in the clashes many are reported to be
injured
their patience was wearing thin
even with the military
they broke down the multi-layer
protective cordons and removed all
barriers from their path for the final
push
security forces were overwhelmed by the
sheer numbers and determination as they
stormed the president's house
some carrying the nation's flag they
walked through the gardens and many
rooms and corridors of the building
warning their president to go
while a few jumped in the swimming pool
to cool off in the most secure address
in the country
president gotabaya rajapaksa had earlier
been evacuated to an undisclosed
location
temple tree the official residence of
prime minister ranil wickramasinghe was
also stormed by protesters
while his private home has been
satellite
the anger against leaders is palpable
after an emergency meeting the prime
minister has agreed to step down for an
all-party government to be formed
what they did was uh they were
trying to be in power using various
methods so today the people
who were
in the struggle they entered the
president house
possibly and
took it into control
the island's 22 million citizens
are facing the worst ever economic
crisis which has triggered shortages of
food medicine and fuel
the deep rooted economic problems have
remained unaddressed for decades
and the rajapaksa government's
mismanaged economic policies has left
the country virtually bankrupt
the government is now in talks for a
three billion dollar bailout with the
international monetary fund
but for the moment it's ordinary sri
lankans who will have to bear the brunt
of the worst man-made disaster the
country is facing
neville lazarus sky news